[Musik]
besichtigt
hallo
dafür kommen soll will israel heute
gehts leckere kekse nicht in einem focus
und zwar habe ich die frühlingshaft
mittelmäßig dekoriert war nicht die
kleine herfielen und karotten und eier
und einige davon sind damit lernen sie
haben alle mit ostern zu tun haben und
uns alles genau da kann man bestimmt ein
theologischer unterschreiben und die
kekse gelassen gefühlt lassen es ist
auch super lecker zu koppeln oder ihr
könnt sie so wie ich auch mit der
kaputten bedrohen foto pas de deux ein
bisschen dekorieren für mich auch sascha
vor allem mit kindern
ich zeige euch jetzt einmal wie ich den
betreuten stuhl habe und seit das dach
nun alle daten wird die kokons kekse
brauch ich 160 computer circa 320 gramm
kalte butter eine prise salz etwas
manila extrakt zweige 300 gramm mehl und
180 gefragt ihr könnt sie kokosraspeln
entweder verlassen dann habt ihr so ein
bisschen struktur drin oder ihr könnt
sie fein mahlen
das mache ich jetzt und zwar nehme ich
jetzt mail und gruppe presse und
verbindet die beiden und gebt einfach
kurze den mix
[Musik]
so wie das koks monats aus also richtig
schön find aber wie gesagt könnte jetzt
auch gerne grob lassen stelle ich jetzt
ganz kurz zur seite und nehme jetzt
butter zucker und gibt es jetzt in eine
rührschüssel ihr könnt den teig ist
entweder mit der küchenmaschine mit dem
handrührgerät mit den knethaken oder
auch mit den händen verkneten problem
ist nur wenn man den teig mit dem händen
verletzt dass er immer weich wird
nämlich butter und puderzucker und
verbindet und etwas von lextra kind hof
und dann kommt dem gesamtsieg auch schon
die zwei eigelb mit rein und dann geht
es jetzt auch gleich das mir dazu immer
nacheinander so dass ein schönes
entsteht
[Musik]
welch ein bisschen mehl und familie
damit meine arbeitsfläche nämlich sind
heraus und falls ihr den teig noch mit
den händen zu bereiten wollt könnt ihr
zum beispiel einen meter neben und den
zwei packen dann deswegen heißt der mit
blick auf aktg oder ihr nehmen zum
beispiel so einen teig hacker dann eben
auch nicht schafe haben sich das heißt
man kann eben auch nicht dran verletzten
und kann so die zutaten auch schon
miteinander verbinden
[Musik]
er verbinde ich den tag einfach kurz mit
den händen und falls er zuvor stift gibt
hier einfach noch ein bisschen mehr das
tun und da kommt die feuchtigkeit jetzt
auch durch die cobra auf fett ist das
heißt coco ist nicht so trocken wie mehl
und deswegen kann sein das ist einfach
ein bisschen mehr mehr benötigt
[Musik]
einen schönen weißen zeigt ihnen gebe
ich jetzt in einem schlüssel zurück in
sack und stellen für mindestens eine
stunde in den kühlschrank durchgeführt
und jetzt werde ich immer so etwa die
hälfte nämlich jetzt raus um den
restlichen zeit wieder in den
kühlschrank stellen dann würde einfach
nicht warm wird und kann nichts sehen
hier weiter verarbeiten
mit knete ich ihn nur ganz leicht durch
wirklich dass er einfach schön
geschmeidig wird und rollen dann auf
dieser silikon masse auf fünf millimeter
stephaudt dafür nehme ich diese zwei
tölzer haben wir einfach immer den
perfekten abstand
[Musik]
da habe ich jetzt hier einen großen
aufsteiger st etienne und für die
doppeldecker legt sie werde ich jetzt
eier nehmen und werde die jeweils
zweimal aus zu hintons später braucht
irgendein eier und die restlichen werde
ich einfach ganz normal mit einer winkel
palette hoch oder auch mit einem messer
zum beispiel da geht's zum einfachen und
legt jetzt schon hier auch ein bug
gleichzeitig meine dauer war folie drauf
[Musik]
die kleinen teile möglichst immer gerne
auf ein zweites paket einfach wegen der
backpfeife brauchen ein bisschen weniger
im backofen alle selbst die großen
misslingt eines kleineren aussteller
entweder den preis oder am herd und
stechens jeweils in jedes zweite allein
damit ich später einfach ein kleiner
werden kann das loch haupt für die
füllung damit der teig nicht trocken und
hart wird 18 ausfallen immer darauf
lasse ich nicht zu viel mehr verwenden
möchte ich die rattle mit dem frischen
teig rolle des weiteren aus und schließt
alle aktien aus und nachdem auf welchen
kommen die dann noch mal nach halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank und war
deswegen damit du deinen backen schöne
reform behalten
[Musik]
werden die kekse beim fahrer hätten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 50 minuten gebacken die großen
gegner habe ich schon drin
die brauchen etwas länger als die
kleinen daher wurde erst schön
kontrollieren john cheever und hell
bleiben
[Musik]
die kick gefehlt alle abdeckkappe zum
abkühlen auf dem gleich gelassen und ist
nach dem abkühlen erst abkühlen ritter
geweckt damit wir eben dran arbeiten
haben die kondition konnte verlassen
oder integriert sind schön das mach ich
jetzt und zwar mit einem butter zucker
zitrone erzielt bei einer trump oder
programm und da gäbe es schon gefunden
wurden sagte dazu und zwar so viel dass
ein schöner dickflüssiger und streichelt
es entsteht bis 31
[Musik]
der coach ist fertig und bin gerne zu
nehmen und auch zum beispiel mit lebens
nur die farbpracht vermischen was ich
eben einfahren kann
ich habe ich jetzt blau rot gelb und
grün die welches gleich verwenden und
wie kann ich dann in einen spritzbeutel
füllen und daneben auf die kekse
streifen findet ganz aber auch für mal
mit pinsel und auftragen und auch mit
einem löffel oder wird als ikonen sind
je nachdem wie detailliert etwas machen
möchte
und sobald der zuckerguss dann
getrocknet oder auch noch im nassen
zustand je nachdem was ihr machen müsste
könnte dann zum beispiel noch die zocker
stift nehmen bietet in so kleinen touren
und sie sind bereits eingeleitet heißt
es schwarz gelb in rosa gold silber blau
weiß und auch andere farben und die kann
ich dann eben auch schon drauf spritzen
und feinheiten
[Musik]
gut
da
[Musik]
weil
es ist ein klares urteil kann getrocknet
und dann können wir bereits mit lampard
gefüllt werden
das landestheater habe ich gerade frisch
zubereitet und ein bisschen mehr futter
verwendet aber dass sie dir das
verhältnis auch in meinem rezept stehen
und jetzt auf dem rad probieren man kann
die kekse man so schön oder ungefüllt
lassen
ja das hätte man kann sie natürlich auch
so laufen aber komplett vor denn für
eine kokosnuss vor allem findest du
patronen und ich mag sie auch gerne so
cool
so kann man natürlich auch wir sind
besser verstauen die dekorierten kekse
legen ich nicht gerne über einander
arbeitet sollen ja auch nur die schöne
kapitals trieren und was ich ganz gut
finde und von ihrer macht auch richtig
viel spaß mit dieser truppe zu arbeiten
da kann man eben eine richtig schöne
deko machen ja als ihr jetzt auch diese
kekse nachmachen wolfgang geht nochmal
das rezept für euch und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß danach machen und wir
werden uns beim nächsten mal
ende
[Musik]